from the minds behind snow white in the
Huntsman and transformers two three and
four
oh no comes the glossy Hollywood
adaptation of a beloved Japanese anime
that goes about as well as you'd expect
ghost in the shell' Hollywood is running
out of stuff from the 80s and 90s to
remake now they're remaking a film
they've already been ripping off for
decades but with controversial casting a
dumbed-down plot new shoes used to do
Panucci auguste just enough recreated
scenes from the anime to put it in the
trailers and a complete lack of
understanding about what made the
franchise popular to begin with because
as Dragonball Evolution taught American
film executives if at first you don't
succeed blame the reviews and learn
nothing from your mistakes you've seen
Scarlett Johansson as a Special Ops
soldier and enhanced human a stoic
outsider a sexy robot voice you feel me
with uranium and a white girl feeling
out of place in Asia
now she'll combine them all as the major
and enhanced Special Ops sexy robot
voice TOEIC outside her white girl who
feels out of place in Asia I don't know
how to trust her anymore
she's a Robocop with a weird Robo walk
and only one weakness getting snuck up
on by dudes with Tasers
you know for all the gadgets maybe
invest in a rear camera watch is the
studio avoids a whitewashing controversy
by showing off how multicultural their
version of Hong Kong is and explaining
that majors body is just a robot shell
for someone else's brain he made you a
new body a synthetic shell but no ghost
which all right I'll bite
then cringe and disbelief as the studio
manages to ruin their own solution by
revealing that yep she was full-blown
Japanese all along what's your name
wait a DoubleDown gang you just try to
put out a dumpster fire with a much
larger easily avoidable dumpster fire
Jackie and as the major teams up with
side characters who get two to four
lines of dialogue led by Japanese legend
beat Takeshi who was smart enough to
know this movie wasn't worth speaking
English for so many think is gone to
Stella she figured up good also do
Donald together they'll chase down an
evil Max Headroom hacker from mine
failure this in a cat-and-mouse game of
shifting loyalties that will have you
wondering can you see your boobs or not
I can't tell and I definitely don't care
what else is going on so please really
boring so gear up for the latest movie
with John Carter syndrome where the
source material was so influential that
now it feels like it's copping the
film's that inspired and witnessed the
newest lame attempt at a live-action
anime film which we should really just
leave to the Japanese at this point
or not
starring turning Japanese oh yes I'm
turning Japanese I really think so cable
beat Takeshi beat beat Takeshi Palpatine
business in the front party in the back
holy crap is that top dollar and literal
whitewashing Bicentennial woman cyber
mech live I been saving up for a while
now it's lost call every night uh guys
your friend is an alcoholic
stop beating lines from Monsters Inc but
Hulk like raging fire Thor like
smoldering fire bad aybe bad eh I am a
glorious Disney Princess who enjoys
tacos I think Aquaman is the best
superhero